para estos artilleros ucranianos no hay
un segundo que perder los servicios de
inteligencia militar acaban de localizar
varios objetivos con la ayuda de aviones
no tripulados que planean sobre ellos
[Música]
los tanques y las trincheras rusas están
ahora en su línea de visión extendidos a
lo largo de las afueras del Oeste De
gerson
vladislav comanda esta unidad está a
cargo de ajustar cada disparo y recibe
información continua antes de cada
decisión
estamos constantemente haciendo
correcciones el último disparo cayó a
cinco o diez metros del objetivo para la
artillería es un buen trabajo infligimos
daños a su Infantería se pusieron a
cubierto pero conseguimos darles la
unidad participa en la contraofensiva
hacia gerson que ha desplegado miles de
soldados aquí con el objetivo de rodear
la capital de la región que fue tomada
por los rusos al comienzo de la guerra
Pero a medida que se acercan a la ciudad
en avance se hace más difícil por ahora
los artilleros vuelven a su base a unas
decenas de kilómetros al oeste de gerson
dicen estar de buen humor
nuestra Infantería está ganando terreno
metro a metro Aunque el terreno sea
difícil estamos haciendo todo lo posible
para ayudarles No creo que nos
detengamos solo en gerson volveremos a
las fronteras de 1991 retomando crimea
porque crimea es parte del territorio
ucraniano
las tropas ucranianas se han mantenido
optimistas en esta carrera contra el
tiempo ahora Solo queda un simple
objetivo por delante recuperar jerson
antes del Invierno